il est avec l'observateur et c'est vrai
alors c'est grâce à moi que tu as eu ton
visa alors oui en général oui général
général c'est grâce à moi que tous vos
visages aujourd'hui anglais l'histoire
on écoute et il ya la vidéo à la fin
vous avez précisé qu'il faut écouter
dans mon jeu a débauché alors raconté en
plus j'avais mon dossier a ajouté le
capture d'écran de la vidéo vous avez
dit que je vais le prendre comme
chroniqueur way et je suis allé déposer
et j'avais mon visage quand j'ai eu mon
visage avait pris vraiment la grosse
tête au blé de là bas j'avais pris la
grosse tête la télévision nationale m'a
appelé vient devenu connu que chez nous
on dit mais vous êtes fous on est
mauvais en france l'a enfin direct et
après je suis arrivé plus rien tu
deviennes connu que denis fischer
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
l'année prochaine tu feras photos des
[Rires]
peintures des factures acte avec nous
pour l'émission si tu veux parce qu'il
est très drôle moi donc tu envisages tu
es content oui tel qu'on le parle de
très beaux chants je suis frais avant
y'avait pas de contours
[Rires]
il est près du confluent gars merci tu
restes avec nous